[Music]
russian flags and honking car horns in
the separatist city of donetsk but this
bestowal of independence which is not
russia's gift to give will not
necessarily bring peace
vladimir putin declaring today he'd
recognized the separatists claims to the
whole of donetsk and luhansk regions not
just the parts they control
we have recognized all fundamental
documents and their constitution
and constitution determines the borders
of
donetsk and lugansk
while they were
part of ukraine but we're counting on
on
resolution of all these
differences
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky whose territory this is called
for an immediate and tough response from
the west
europe and the world could not allow the
repetition of the tragic mistakes made
in georgia in 2008.
we agreed on the necessity of
immediately imposing sanctions for
another action of aggression against
ukraine
these sanctions must include the
complete shutdown of nordstrom 2.
and as if on cue the german chancellor
obliged
minister
i have asked the german economy ministry
today to withdraw the report on the
analysis of the energy supply guarantees
from the german regulator it sounds
technical but it's the required
procedure so that there can be no
certification of the pipeline now
without this certification nordstrom 2
can't become operational
russia's upper house has now authorized
the deployment of the russian armed
forces in the separatist republics as
and when it's deemed that they're needed
but are they already there
[Music]
unmarked military convoys on the roads
of the republics last night though not
much to go on beyond these pictures
declaring the breakaway republic's
independent is one thing pushing further
into ukraine is another
both are clearly invasions of ukrainian
sovereignty but one would involve a lot
more bloodshed the question is is
vladimir putin a rational actor or has
he let his emotions and the bubbling
resentments of years if not decades get
the better of him
again he returned to an imaginary threat
of a one-day nuclear ukraine
ukraine since soviet times
had
quite an extensive
nuclear competences they've got several
nuclear units and their nuclear industry
is well developed 110 kilometers can be
increased to 300 to 500 kilometers
and then moscow will be
within the the reach of these rockets
for us this is a strategic
threat
ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons 30
years ago in exchange for security
assurances from the likes of russia
president putin first broke those
promises eight years ago in crimea and
he continues to trample on them now
dinah magnus sky news moscow